all right guys
bang bang i've got congressman emmer
here uh thank you so much for doing this
hey pam thanks for having me absolutely
so
uh for like the five people watching who
uh who don't know who you are give us
kind of a quick two minutes
uh what you did before you got uh into
politics and then kind of uh what you do
today
so i was i i i well what did i do i
played hockey through college
i was going to head to europe wanted to
play in europe i
and met the girl when i got back to
minnesota before i made the next step
met the girl that i knew that night i
was going to marry her
it took her a little while longer but i
knew
we just celebrated our 34th anniversary
last weekend
uh we have uh seven kids six boys and a
daughter
i was doing this thing pop raisin them
like we do
you know we moved to a small town about
40 miles west of uh downtown minneapolis
i got an 80-acre farm behind me you know
we're on an acre lot
the kids can bike they can go to the
local meat market i mean it was great uh
growing up and i was doing what
what a lot of americans do right
coaching all their sports being involved
in all this stuff
and then something happened back in 2004
where i'm sitting on the front sidewalk
my wife and i after church had left
those guys to
do their chores on a sunday morning
drove to a neighboring town grabbed a
cup of coffee and were reading the
sunday paper i said look at this look at
this the guy who's our state rep he's uh
he's not going to run again
surprise surprise i mean it might have
something to do with carrying that
loaded gun through the airport but
that's
neither here nor there but what happened
at that point is my wife looked at me
and said
you should do that and i laughed i said
you got to be kidding me why would
i mean we got seven kids peak earning
years why would i
ever run for the state legislature my
wife is a beauty she says
hey aren't you the one that says you
shouldn't complain if you're not going
to do anything about it
so i ran for the state house back in
2004 in minnesota
i'm a minnesota kid my wife's a
minnesota kid
i uh the only thing that's unique
is i'm a graduate of the university of
alaska in fairbanks alaska
and i lived in the woods in a cabin with
no running water outdoor plumbing and
wood heat
which some of my old teammates tell me
prepared me for congress but anyway
fast forward i ended up running for this
uh seat in uh
2004 was elected in two i'm sorry 14
elected in 2015 and it's been a unique
experience i wanted to be part of the
financial services committee
because i believe our monetary system
our opportunity our financial system at
least
in the past has been what separates the
united states of america from
every other country on the face of the
planet it is the definition of our
freedom
this is the only country where you and i
at least we used to be able to
it's getting worse because these
do-gooders with election certificates
keep rushing in to save us all from
ourselves and
they cause more trouble than they do uh
solve problems
but this has been the only country where
a dumb schlub like me
can come up with a great idea and go sit
down with a local banker it used to be
now we've got all kinds of options one
of which i don't want to see government
screw up and that's the crypto area
but we can sit down with somebody that
wants to join us
in taking a risk they want to help us by
providing necessary capital
that allows us to open the next great
harley-davidson in our garage
the next great medtronic in our garage
walt disney
and i mean every one of these companies
that started with an idea in the garage
that's what makes this country
frankly different from every every other
country in the face the planet and
it's funny i'm going to tell you as a
side story pomp that uh
i got here i get on the financial
services committee one of the first
things we got was a meeting
over at the federal reserve with uh then
uh
chair yellen and uh dr stanley fisher
one of the board members and
uh jay powell who was then one of the
governors whatever you call them their
titles
and i asked him what they were doing to
create
more opportunities in the financial
services industry
and back then pomp i was talking
specifically about bank charters right
uh which by the way i think the action
by brian brooks last week could be very
good
when we talk about banks but we can get
to that in a minute i
i said to him you guys have been
suffocating
this uh the lower end of the financial
services
uh spectrum dr stanley fisher god bless
him i don't really know him
but he told me his response was well
you know it's it's because they can't
keep up the smaller banks can't keep up
with the uh
with the uh computer technology he said
to him
hey man why don't you come to minnesota
and we'll go up to halleck
where i think they're still using the
old-fashioned ledger
and they're keeping track of everybody
the old-fashioned way
you know you guys got to get out of the
way you get so involved
and here's what scared me the meeting
ended
you know and we're kind of socializing
around the table this was an amazing
room talk about the star chamber the
federal reserve is
i mean i'd heard stories i had to see it
myself
this is uh the room that i'm told where
the joint chiefs of staff
would literally meet during world war ii
so we're standing having side
conversations
dr fisher comes over to me and he says
i don't know what you're so worried
about he says
this is exactly the way they do it in
germany and it works just fine and i
said
that is what's scaring me okay i
you that the idea and and when we get
into what
you want to talk about which is this
exciting area
which as i told you before you turn on
the tape i'm never going to claim to be
the expert i've never
for me it's kind of like doing this by
the braille method
you know i got a great staffer here
that's a minnesotan
who's been interested in this stuff
since i came to congress
and he made the mistake or i i he
good fortune of handing me a book called
the age of cryptocurrency
about i don't know four years ago five
years ago and i i read the book i told
him afterwards
i don't think he ever expected me to
read it i read a cover to cover i
i went back to him and i said you know
the problem with his book
there are not pictures i'm in congress
and you didn't get me a book with
pictures
but after joking around with them a
little bit it was like i got to know
more about this thing
i i know the way i've been raised pomp
i see things in one and two dimension we
were just talking about computers the
other day you know i started in a law
office
where everything was in paper and what
separated you from other lawyers was you
could find that
one piece of paper in a banker's box or
four and you could find it in 20 seconds
right because that's the one
the guy in the stands lying about it let
me ask you about this
guess what you guys you've been raised
totally different
you see the world in this abstract
you're able to be out here my kids do
this
right they see it in two and three
dimension
and i fear perhaps even beyond that i
just uh
i watch what you guys are capable of
doing and i
two things and i'm excited to be doing
this with you because
as we go forward people in this place
called congress have to start catching
up or just get the hell out of the way
all right because if you're just gonna
frustrate things because you don't
understand what's going on or
you're not willing to open your mind up
to the possibility that the next great
advance is out there and i'll stop there
pomp i'll let you drive it because here
we're coming out of a crisis and i do
think we're coming out of it
for anybody listening i think you're
going to hear about a vaccine shortly
more importantly
i think you're going to hear about
therapeutics right we're going to be
able to treat people
in certain demographics who right now
this virus is
fatal to them if we can treat them so
that they can recover
that's is good i mean not as great as a
vaccine but
you're saving lives and i think we're
going to get there but think about what
we're going to get
we're coming out of this thing we've now
been forced
to work remotely we've now been forced
to learn remotely we've now been forced
to
uh treat with our health care providers
remotely and the list goes
on and on so now two things have to
happen
one we gotta build out the next great
transportation system
in america and forgive me but i am
competitive
i think it should be here and i think it
should be the best
and i don't mind if our canadian friends
and our mexican friends and everybody
else
comes along with us but we are the best
place for this to happen if those of us
that have election certificates
and the regulators would just get up to
speed or get out of the way
the key though we're not going backward
we're not going to go back to a day
where you got to go see the doctor
to have him tell you what you already
know oh yeah you got a cold let's see
i'll give you this
we're going forward and that means we're
going to have to build out the rest of
this internet highway
we're going to have to increase the
speeds and we're going to need
i'm going to tell you we're going to
move into this area i don't think cash
is ever gone
because i'm also one of those guys that
i don't like the government following my
every move
as you might guess despite my white hair
you probably know my attitude it's more
libertarian i think than
uh anything but this this is the future
it's called valuable exchange between
human beings
without a middleman why not
so one of the things i want to talk
about before we get into bitcoin and
kind of cryptocurrencies
is uh there's a lot of people who are
looking and saying we've got two
financial systems right now
and the legacy one is uh under duress
right so there's this virus we go
through the government mandated
lockdowns at the state levels
and now all of a sudden it leads to this
financial crisis
and as you mentioned to and alluded to
earlier the government response and the
federal reserve spot
response in these situations is to just
start printing a bunch of money and
handing it out in every nook and cranny
in every exotic way they can think of
just talk a little bit i think about
kind of how you view
the response so far where we've made
mistakes and kind of what can we do from
here moving forward
in the legacy fiat world to address the
issues at hand
so let me start uh even earlier let's go
back to uh the early 70s 1972
and i'm going to talk to you not as a
professor in finance or masters in
finance because i'm not
i'm just a guy from the midwest who's
kind of learned it by the braille method
right
uh 1972 kind of interesting
why did we take the dollar
off the gold standard why well because
they wanted to grow the pie without any
regulation
and that's a problem because that's the
date i believe and you don't have to
agree with me
those uh listeners of yours those six
people that are out there they don't
have to agree with the thing i say
but i believe that was the beginning of
where we went from being a country
and an economy that was based on the
creation of wealth
wealth creation because the idea is if
pop
is creating wealth and tom is working or
involved in commerce with pomp oh my
goodness
you lift up my standard of living too
and it's all based on the creation of
wealth wealth creation
the problem was when you took it off you
no longer pegged
the currency now you can do with it
whatever you want it's all hocus pocus
and what does it become now we start
creating debt instead of wealth
it's debt imagine the greatest
generation that came out of the
depression how they felt about this
they knew how to save they knew how to
plan they knew how to be ready for the
next great whatever it is
this group they're so highly leveraged
right now and this is a problem all the
way around the world
that all they're trying to do is protect
themselves i mean
this is not about well maybe it is about
you maybe maybe you and i are in that
whatever but
what's happened over time in my lifetime
and and this isn't republican or
democrat this is
monetary policy the rich
have gotten richer the middle class
has gotten poorer there's a bigger gap
between the two
why well it's the same reason and i'll
use it with uh the great dodd-frank law
okay unlike some of my republican
colleagues yeah there probably should
have been some better
uh regulation applying to some of the
largest
most integrated financial institutions
on the planet
and yes we do have a need for financial
institutions to be able to cross borders
and do things that are worldwide as
opposed to local
so there's an argument that you need to
have everyone in the financial services
food chain
but when you pass dodd-frank and you
applied
the standard that was intended for the
goldman sachs
the jp morgans the citibanks the wells
fargos when you did that and you applied
it
all the way down the food chain the only
way you can survive
is if you get bigger and bigger so no we
don't have bank failures going on
but we had over 9 000 i think it was
community banks
at the time of the crash the last crash
in 2008
since dodd-frank has been by the way a
year after the crash we still had
roughly the same number of uh community
banks
since dodd-frank was passed we're now
down to six thousand
and it's because and you don't have bank
failures going on
no what you have is absorption all right
so uh
it anyway that's what's happened you
went off the gold standard it doesn't
have to be the gold standard it's
pegging it to some responsible number
so it has meaning as opposed to just
people playing with it
and has some of us wondering why right
so over time in order for you to be
successful
you have to be able to hedge that debt
you have to be able to have enough
resources
to play that game and that's why the
game gets
smaller or the the gap gets bigger i'm
sorry
uh so now uh you're right
we have responded in a very unique way i
believe it's to protect a lot of
investments but i also believe
that it was much more serious in april
this time they played the game up to the
point and again this is
my opinion i don't have any basis except
for this
life experience and what i'm feeling as
i watch this happen
because i i actually published a thing
the night before the the cares act that
said this vote
is the classic hobson's choice the
number one issue i i hadn't voted
uh as far as i know i hadn't voted to
increase spending at all since i got
here
the debt to me is the issue right
i but i wrote it's the it's the classic
or ultimate hobson's choice because on
the one hand
we can't be doing this i mean this is
morally
not responsible it's not just our kids
that we're stealing from right now
it's our great grandkids and perhaps our
great great grandkids
if they ever get to see the light of day
under what we're doing
so it's not just that but the other part
of it was okay so you vote against it
and all of these people and entities who
have built their entire
world around debt creation in this uh
semi uh to me uh
fantasy like uh a system i
it could all crash and if it all comes
down
this isn't just uh like 2008 where it's
the banks
because i think there was a different
way to handle that one this one
is our food supply this one i mean it is
it is
everything people's retirements that
we've wrapped up in this thing so
uh we we do need to find our way through
it and i think we're going to i think
you're
going to hear like i said earlier
therapies vaccine
we'll start to get back to work we're
going to have a lot of work to do and
then it's going to be up to a lot of us
to be voices in here trying to convince
these people it's time to get back to
wealth creation and it's time to look
at new forms of uh of
uh transfer yeah
i think one of the interesting things a
lot of people don't know but i've spent
a lot of time talking about this is the
last
six uh fiscal years we've actually had
record levels of
uh income tax revenue for the government
yet somehow the
deficit gets bigger and bigger and it's
this whole idea of it's not a thing of
can we collect more money it's just
the more money we collect we keep
spending more and more and so that seems
to be this this debt-based system that
you're talking about
and you're leaving out the tariffs i
mean we're not just
income tax we've been collecting all
these tariffs a lot
a ton of money has been coming into the
treasury and i
you know i've said this to uh the
administration i said it when they first
got here
and they said well we need you to vote
for this i said i can't
well why i said because you have to give
me a plan
on how we're going to pay this off if
you have a plan that i believe is
credible
i can go home and sell that otherwise
i'm not playing
uh they told me then and i took them at
their word right you uh you take over
in 2000 what was it 16 when they took
office
they take over and they inherit an
economy that is really churning at less
than 2 percent
it was probably 1.7 1.8 and the thing
that we don't talk about enough is that
number
that includes government spending which
you know i don't know maybe maybe you'll
like the analogy and if you don't
correct me because i've been using it
for years and i feel like people don't
understand it
so we lump both of these together the
private sector which is
actually generating income right growth
and the government sector which is
literally taking that money
out of the private sector and then
putting it back in
it's like living in the same room with
all the
ventilation closed off and the air is
just getting old and stale
and by the way i was told by one witness
when i first got here in the financial
services committee
that government spending could be as
much as one percent of uh gdp
well if that's the case back in 2016 so
you got .7
growth i mean because that's really the
you know the growth
that funnels new and grows the pie and
i told them back then we they told me we
gotta have growth
right now we don't have enough growth
okay great but
pomp when you get to three percent or
better when you're humming the way they
were humming
we should have had a plan i believe last
july
show me how we're going to pay it off
and that's kind of where i am right now
i and i know i'm probably going to be in
the minority but we've spent way too
much money
i mean when there's one trillion dollars
still sitting out there and it hasn't
even been deployed
right and that doesn't even include you
know my state uh
they put 2.1 billion into the minnesota
state treasury
how much of that has been spent yet i
don't maybe half
i mean you got all this money still
sitting out there and the do-gooders
with election certificates
are playing all kinds of politics which
i don't know why we're so arrogant is to
believe we can't be the soviet union or
the weimar republic
and uh it's going to be really
interesting as we go forward to see what
as you call it the legacy system what
it's able to do because
remember the other piece of it before
trump
trump's been separating a lot of these
but it was so
intertwined globally and i i think uh
you know we you look at the european
union
man my mother had a phrase fast
yeah i'm telling you may appreciate this
my mother had a phrase for me when i was
a kid
it was tommy you're way too smart to be
so darn
stupid so i love
that um so the reason i wanted to talk
is uh
the twitter hack happened where uh
basically people took over the twitter
accounts of
many you know well-known people and they
sent out a bitcoin wallet address and
said you know send me money and i'll
send you more back so it's obvious scam
um and you tweeted out and said bitcoin
isn't the problem
centralization is and so maybe talk a
little bit about kind of what you meant
with that tweet and then we'll parlay
that into
a conversation about bitcoin well two
and i was counseled again tonight by
land and hey we've been very careful you
know we've
been critical of some of these big tech
folks when it's appropriate to be
critical
look twitter's a problem they're the
ones that screwed up
bitcoin didn't screw up twitter you your
security was not adequate
they hacked twitter and and you're gonna
have bad guys all over the place so
my my view of it is uh the
centralization
which by the way reminds me of something
i wanted to bring up to you
about the future right because you see
what governments are doing that are
working on fiat currency
you know it's right now they're
they can't really control it but they
are because they're controlling us
but we've got to be careful when we and
this is why i don't like
centralized control this is where this
goes you realize when covid was in full
bloom
in china that the government basically
shut everybody down
you're on a uh you know crypto is not
the right word but
you're uh the government has your
currency all on a card and guess what
if you lived in wuhan they shut you down
man
you couldn't get a ride out of wuhan to
another city
you couldn't go get some groceries
unless the government released you to go
get the groceries so
i need i say more about what i don't
like about centralized control i
you know it's kind of like libra was
proposed uh oh great concept
wonderful but somebody's got to be in
control right
and i want to just uh take it back a
couple notches
and then superimpose uh this
centralization
within the uh crypto area on this
so uh hayek is an austrian economist
who wrote a nice little story to his
intellectual elite buddies
during world war ii when he was not
living in austria he was living in
london
i you might be familiar with the road to
serfdom
he talks to his elite intellectual
buddies because they all want the same
thing right pop they
i want you to be happy i want me to be
happy i want you to have the basic
necessities of life and be able
because we can all live here happily
ever after and we can support each other
this whole thing he said it's great but
you're forgetting this concept of
scarcity and i'm really gonna condense
this
but scarcity is this idea that resources
are scarce
and the free market it's your effort
it's your ingenuity etc that allocates
those resources
but in this socialized atmosphere or
centralized there has to be someone
or some group that decides the
allocation
now that works out pretty good if you're
the one that's
in that group or is that guy but after a
while
if you're not in the group if you're not
the one making the decisions on the
allocation
this thing only ends one way
and it has never been good no matter
where it's been tried
i think we're just moving into that next
phase
which is why uh crypto the area excites
me
because do i think that government has a
role
yeah i'm not going to say no i i don't
think it has a big role
i mean i think government has a i think
people
can police themselves right uh i i don't
like the fact that my colleagues think
everybody is so dumb they're all gonna
get fleeced all the time
and my goodness we gotta rush in you
know the greatest game
is through the greatest risk the
greatest thing about america is
we are supposed to be free to take those
risks
and by the way unlike these other
societies
sometimes we fall off the mountaintop we
end up
laying in the valley but the beauty is
we can get up tomorrow
and we can start climbing again i just
uh
so no i'm i'm sorry but the
centralization thing
to me it's just much bigger than why do
you not like centralization it's a whole
concept of where this thing ultimately
leads somebody is in control
and so obviously bitcoin is the complete
opposite of that right kind of
fully decentralized it is 21 million
artificially capped and as scarce as
any money on the world uh in the world
right many people i think in the bitcoin
world would just call it the soundest
money
the history's ever seen how do these two
worlds either
co-exist or is there a transition later
like
how do you think about this idea of
bitcoin having properties that are
uh interesting and attractive yet
basically the entire world being built
on this fiat system that is debt laden
and really kind of majority of people
have just bought into and
as you said earlier if it was to fail
there would be catastrophic
um kind of effects from that how do
those two systems move forward together
well see you know i i know that uh the
statement
that is the majority of the world is
true uh whether it's europe the u.s
uh canada i mean pick your country it's
uh the traditional
fiat currency is uh now they don't all
manage it well i think i had at one
point
100 million zimbabwe dollar that was
worth like
36 cents or something i don't even know
if it was worth that
but here's where i push back just a
little bit pomp and i i don't mind if
you uh
if you get critical of me and push me
but uh you go to africa
the uh uh nairobi the biggest
slum ever they're using
cash on electronic cash
i mean their system they've in it it's
advanced beyond where we're at now
granted it's centralized right so
that's a different issue but you also
have cultures uh
somali culture for instance where
there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of fear there's a lot you
know people are unbanked
it's still traditional forms of exchange
it in cash
right there they found other ways to
deal
look i hope the traditional fiat
currency
survives i hope that we never
get rid of completely a uh
a tangible form of exchange because
i and somebody they haven't passed a law
against me saying it yet they might
but i don't need the government tracking
what i'm doing they have no right to
know what i'm doing
and you know what frankly they they have
too much information already
i i prefer to keep that separate
this i see the future and i know a lot
of my colleagues don't
and if any of them hear this they're
going to say oh i see where he's going
but i i prefer to have the government
out of the middle
right i our government is supposed to be
severely limited
severely limited and we've allowed it to
become this huge
thing where you know we're gonna have
the opportunity
if we do this right in the next 20 30
50 years you're going to be able to live
wherever you want to live
you're going to be able to treat with
your doctors you're going to be able to
get because of robotics and the uh the
advances there's going to be a day where
you're going to get surgeries you're
going to get
everything and you're going to have for
instance you've got to have a new hip
it's going to be printed up by a 3d
printer
and you're going to have the surgery
right in your home
i mean there are things that are going
to happen going forward
that are going to in my my mind not just
disrupt
the centralized nature of our society
you remember
when people come to this country it's
very spread out i mean you had your your
centers but why did you have your urban
centers
well primarily because you were bringing
in agricultural product
to the urban center to be packaged and
then shipped out on major waterways
and then later when you had the
industrial revolution now
the labor came in from the rural areas
and was concentrated in the factories in
the city
so that you could use the same
transportation methods
we're just about to blow that whole
thing up we are on the verge because of
this pandemic i believe
of starting to really think differently
and it's not going to be me
it's not going to be me i don't have the
ability to grasp
this thing but i do have i i hope enough
sense to recognize
that even though i don't like change i'm
going to be able to live my life
in the way that i've lived it if the
government doesn't take it away from me
beforehand i'm sorry i'm not wearing my
mask too i'll have to get that on later
i told him i told him i need a you know
don't tread on me
and then the fubar and all these other
things it's uh
very politically incorrect but i see a
day
when that total you know
decentralization
is possible and now what you're talking
about
it's not just cash right you've got to
have this other system
i and it's either going to happen
because we have people who are
visionaries
who are looking beyond and working with
people who are smart enough to tell you
hey this is how we could do this or i'm
afraid you're going to have to have a
catastrophe that forces it to happen i
mean
you know better than i do the reason i
read the age of cryptocurrency because
this mysterious satoshi
because of the last crash in 2008
didn't think we were going to have fiat
currency we better get to work right
well we're not that far after that we're
just 12 years later and we're going
through this pandemic
kind of funny uh landon was telling me
today that uh bitcoin
traded up it's uh well when i think a
lot of people who
uh who end up being a fan of sound money
in general right
they basically look at the macro system
today and they say hey we're printing a
bunch of money
whether it's bitcoin or gold you're
going to see those things
increase in u.s dollar value we're
devaluing the dollar and obviously those
things are going to increase
in value um there's people in the gold
community that say oh the
the solution to this is to go back to a
gold standard right
i tend to think uh unlikely that that
will happen although i understand the
argument
what's more likely is that every fiat
currency in the world just digitizes so
you get a digital dollar digital euro
digital yen you know one all the way
through
and then you basically don't have
competition at the technology layer
because now whether it's bitcoin it's a
private currency like libra
it's a digital dollar it's all digitized
and where the competition plays out is
at the monetary
policy level is that in line i know that
you've done a bunch of work on the
digital dollar and in the blockchain
caucus and kind of all of that work but
just
how are you guys thinking about digital
dollar bitcoin
libra and kind of where that competition
plays out well
so uh two things first you talked about
devaluing the dollar
i'm going to suggest to you uh that
there may be people here in washington
right now
that really think they can play with
this funny money all the way through the
end of the year and they can continue to
print trillions of dollars
because they'll say two things one well
we'll just devalue the dollar
and when you complain about it you know
what their answer is yeah but our
exports i mean people will buy a lot
more stuff
that's not the answer pop that's not
monetary policy
that's greed that's just uh you know and
that's
also just kicking the can down the road
for tomorrow
but the digital dollar first off i
i don't like the idea of uh every
country and that's what we're looking at
i mean i could tell you that the bankers
that i work with good guys
one of my colleagues has really done
some work since we got here
on getting up to speed on uh on this
cryptocurrency area and what it means
and he's a traditional banker
and he did not start with that uh with
that view
uh but i don't think he'd go where i
want to go
and where i want to go is you're not
going to get competition
if you turn it over to the government
you're going to get what they see in
china okay because remember pop
somebody has to be in control i prefer
that if we're doing a uh
if we're working at cryptocurrency
you're in control of your wallet
i'm in control of my wallet and you and
i
are doing the exchange between us
because i don't need big brother one
watching what we're doing uh two i don't
need
and i know this whole bit about uh know
your customer
and that's just gone way overboard
that's
you can become a prisoner of your own
safety and security and that is what
we've done
we just keep putting up these we got
more people that come in and
you know it's like we have to do this
because
you know what pomp is gonna the chinese
are gonna do this to them or they're
gonna steal whatever
or this uh terrorist group uh
no no i don't think so um
i i just don't see it and while there
is uh a place for it again you can
probably tell
i tend to to not my view
by the way i'm in the minority at this
point
i'm in the minority what would it take
for
a single state so we saw the state of
ohio for example the treasurer's office
said hey
we're gonna accept bitcoin for taxes uh
when that treasurer transitioned out it
basically was reversed almost
immediately right
yeah i i joked with josh mandel who's
the treasurer who did it
i said it was like a one-man show who
got something through and then the
second he walked out of the room
everyone you know rearranged the room
back to how it was before
what would it take in your state or
another state to
really kind of adopt some of this stuff
as
a second currency is that something that
has to have buy-in across
kind of everywhere from the local all
the way up to the state is that a state
you know top-down thing like how does
that work oh i think it's going to have
to come from the bottom up
and it's actually both ways right and
i'm just looking because we've got a
bill
that we did on uh state licensing
i think it starts with stuff like that
it might seem not very sexy
right uh but wait a second if the
federal government
creates a one-size-fits-all when you're
dealing with
the exchange of uh crypto and
you now don't have to get a money
transmitting license in every single
state and then they start
micromanaging because you got people in
those offices that don't know what's
going on
so you create that that type of stuff
one
will allow it will take away the 50
state patchwork right in the in the in
the district
uh that will help but then you're going
to have to have pressure from the bottom
and the pressure from the bottom we've
got talent
right uh and when we've got uh capital
that will one both leave this country
they will go find a place for this to
work the dollar
or the bitcoin will always follow the
path of least resistance
so if we want to be behind the eight
ball which we already are in some cases
we can continue to let this go the
second thing is
once you start doing money transmitter
license bills
once you have uh brian brooks what he
did last week
by allowing uh banks to to uh
to actually bank the uh uh
take custody of crypto assets what he
did there
that signal really gets the ball rolling
now we got a problem with
maybe the secretary of the treasury
maybe you know
a former sec uh adviser our
secretary whatever you call them
chairman
but you've got a lot of people and it's
growing on the inside of these
institutions
and that's why brian brooks i met with
him a few weeks ago and just
so grateful that they put him there
right
uh but it has to pick up momentum
because
here's the other thing and you work with
the people
in this area a lot more than i do i get
to meet them they're interesting
i mean i love the ones that go out and
start a trading platform that's worth
millions
and they never graduated from usc but
guess what
usc invites them back because they want
to give them an honorary degree and have
them talk to their students that are
paying an exorbitant amount
for a worthless education much of the
time
you know it's that old how much do you
spend for your college education
uh 250 000 and
what's your daughter doing welcome to
arby's can i take your order
um but the uh i think
once it it starts to roll and you get
the pressure
here here's the other thing i'll leave
it with this you got really smart
young people in this area they're going
to figure out a way to get around the
rules
this is where i i've said this in other
places
this is where the roman empire went when
the citizens didn't know and didn't care
for years
that the government had actually fallen
i mean think about it was it spain just
a couple years ago
they didn't have a government for over a
year and their economy was actually
improving huh
that's a head scratcher not really
so it's people that you're interviewing
all the time it's people that you're
intersecting and interacting with
they're going to figure out how to do
this
and government can actually help
facilitate it
and then make sure you know where and i
think the community is the best to help
us with this
where we need to lean in right where
there are
dangers where there are bad guys where
there are
the thing that bothers me the most and
sorry it just triggered me when i said
bad guys
it seemed at the beginning like all of
my colleagues democrat and republican
alike
every time you mentioned bitcoin or
crypto they all they heard was silk
road that's why bringing up twitter i'm
very grateful of because
they did it again right it wasn't
bitcoin it caused the problem it was
twitter
and it's it's like every time there's
this
maybe it's because it's the name maybe
crypto just gives it a bad
you know oh there's something bad going
on there it's cryptic
but i think i think one of the other key
pieces to this whole thing
is um five years ago
most people in an elected seat knew
absolutely nothing
fast forward now it's still not
prevalent i think with everybody but
obviously
you are very up to uh up to speed on
this stuff and
you know folks like warren davidson and
kind of you go down the line like
there's a number of people who have
really spent the time
david schweikert yeah and and can not
only articulate
here's why this stuff is important i
think the part uh
at least coming from the bitcoin
community's view is uh when the libra
hearings were going on to see
multiple elected officials say things on
you know the congressional hearing floor
or whatever
like you can't stop bitcoin right you
cannot shut it down
and to kind of have those things um said
out loud publicly
from elected officials it shows that
wait a second the same thing that you
know the computer
kind of nerds and then the entrepreneurs
and the investors
and it kind of spiraled out to the rest
of the world every single one of these
groups has had this aha of this is what
this thing is
and now it's literally seeping into the
halls of government and
when you kind of see somebody flip over
and say wait a second like this is
really interesting
and this is with the value prop i think
that that eventually it's 100
everyone understands it's just how long
does that take well it's it's so
i wish i could answer that question but
what you just said so i told you when we
started
uh uh tonight that i read the book
age of cryptocurrency when i gave it
back to landon i
i said uh after i made the joke about
the pictures i said
this is one of the most interesting
things i've ever read and i actually met
uh the authors in new york a couple
years ago and i told him the same thing
but it it started me down this road and
i told him i need more stuff
landon looks at me and he says you
realize that if you're not the most
educated you're in the top five when it
comes to this right now in congress and
i said there's no way
he said look there's polis from colorado
there's uh schweikert from arizona
there's uh mulvaney and i don't know how
educated he was but this was mulvaney's
deal he he's one of the founders of the
blockchain caucus which
i now have the honor of of being one of
the chairs
and why is that important because we
were talking about three four
five people five years ago take a look
at who's in the caucus now
it's grown much bigger and i mean i give
bill foster a hard time behind his back
so if he listens to this is great
i he's not exactly the most charismatic
vibrant uh you know and he always says
i'm a uh scientist or whatever it is his
phd
he's he's bright but even bill
is like grabbing a hold of it and uh you
know trying to understand it
uh steve lynch not quite there yet right
uh but i think he's doing the work
and so the fact that he starts out from
a place that may not be what we agree
with
the fact that he gets into it i got to
tell you pomp if you do your homework
if you start getting exposed to the
people it'll change
quickly so you know that's three years
now three four years i don't know though
that
you know somebody told me when i first
ran for office you're not going to be
very happy because getting government to
move is kind of like turning a super
tanker at sea
and you wanted to like turn on a dime uh
i just don't think we can afford to let
this go
six eight ten years i it's just not i
think uh
the number of people and you've got some
democrats now on the other side that are
really smart financial guys i'm not
going to give you the names because you
know
i'm just not going to give them the
ability to say hey tom emmer says
i'm this in their next campaign but they
are
they're good okay and uh i think that
combined with the
growing number of republicans i i think
you're gonna get uh
and by the way end the crisis because as
we come out of the crisis
bitcoin ain't going away it's gonna get
stronger
and now brian brooks is saying hey
institutions you can start uh banking
this stuff
right you can you can provide a home for
it you can start working with it
number one uh issue when i was in the
the last campaign
i go to nebraska lincoln nebraska i
think it was
uh which a lot of banks a lot of
insurance companies
very understated most people don't know
that uh
it's it's a big center for financial
stuff
i had a round table i had a couple of
the bigger insurance companies
their leaders i had three or four banks
and there were three young guys sitting
right next to me and there's
tables that are in a square and i don't
know who they are they're they
i mean they they're a little older than
my kids but they're definitely they
don't look like this
they got you know they got the good nice
hair they're young
they're you know and this whole meetings
going on
i'm about a halfway through it comes out
these guys are in the blockchain space
these guys are in the crypto space
and they instantly start pointing the
finger at the banks
you aren't helping us we're going to
london
we're going to you know wherever we're
leaving
because we can i and the banks of course
pointed at the occ
i think brian brooks so short answer
your question
all these things are starting to come
together right now he is
we have got to continue to raise these
voices
because if you get the momentum and
we're going to have this
ugly election it's going to be so
terrible
and i mean don't uh anybody who checks
me out
i am definitely involved in the election
process and i definitely have a
perspective
but i'm not looking forward to it for
our country
i'm just not i you know after uh after
labor day
everybody's gonna strap their helmet on
and it's gonna be this bloody brutal
but when we get through it i really
you know combined with what i told you
earlier about therapies and vaccines
when we come through that i'm hoping
that much like a forest fire
you see this beautiful new growth start
to come out the other side in the
springtime because
we just can't keep doing the garbage
that we're doing at the federal level
and expect this country
to one actually find their government
credible
or to survive the way we want our
american way of life to survive
i and that will be the opportunity pom i
believe that's the opportunity when we
come
out of that as long as we have new
leadership
and people are talking to each other
again and you know you stop this
lockdown stuff
and and just making everything about us
and them instead of about we
i think we can make a big gate because
tied together we're not going backward
when it comes to the
internet super highway we're going to
have to go forward
i completely agree uh we've got about
four or five minutes left and uh asked
everybody the exact same question to end
which is uh
aliens usually i ask believer or
non-believer but you
are a elected member of the us
government
and there's been lots of uh ufo talk
recently
what uh what's your take on aliens ufos
and uh and any of that stuff
look man i'm i'm my i'm 59 years old
i got a tough enough time with my own i
hope there
are i hope there are how's that i mean
how cool would that be that there's a
civilization
somewhere else you know i'm i'm to that
point in my life that i'm not going to
be walking on another planet but you
might still have that opportunity and
yeah i don't i
i and this is going to be embarrassing
but i haven't seen the recent ufo talk
was it a uh
were we talking about a presidential
campaign or
well so here's the crazy part right is
i've asked the you know 300 something
number of people this thing and usually
the most popular answer is some form of
uh we would be ignorant and arrogant to
believe we're the only
intelligent life in the you know in the
galaxy who says we're intelligent
that's a whole nother conversation but
but i think that the the thing that's so
funny is
um the ufos everyone immediately thinks
aliens and all i keep telling people is
wait a second
a ufo just means that we can't figure
out how something scientifically works
right but at some point there was in
human history people who didn't
understand gravity
and then they figured that out right and
so there's this whole balance between
like aliens and ufos that other people
you and me were meant to talk today
because
earlier today people were talking about
some of the strangest things that you
encounter when you're doing the job that
i do and i got the guys who were
you know every i'd go to this place a
little legion
in my district and there'd be this guy
waiting for me with a stack of papers
i want to talk about gmos and i'd be
like well genetically modified whatever
you got to understand they're just
speeding up the evolution no man
no and then it'd be like you got to be
against fluoride you got to be and by
the way the mercury that's in the uh
this is uh
it's every conspiracy thing that we
could think of and i told him when i was
doing radio a few years ago
you'd get to call in and say did you see
the big
all-white dc-9 that was flying around
downtown minneapolis no
tell me more it was chemtrails
that's what they were doing tell me more
tell me more no it's
look i i had a friend in the legislature
a great democrat he's dead now
tommy rukavina we called him tommy the
commie he was a great guy
he once told me he said emmer we all
believe in black helicopters
we just think different people are
flying them
look it's true right i i joke all the
time marketing and propaganda is the
same thing it's just which uh which
you know side you believe yeah and what
are you trying to accomplish
absolutely uh if you can leave everyone
with uh with one or two sentences just
on kind of how you see
bitcoin blockchain and america's future
what would it be
uh two things one bitcoin blockchain
it's
not going away it's going to continue to
become more and more
important and it's going to advance i
you just watch it has value and when
something has value
people are going to take more risks and
it's going to advance
and for america the sun's going to come
up again
it's going to shine again and not just
here but around the world we got some
troubles there's no question but this
happens in in the world in world history
uh you just gotta remain positive you
gotta be grateful for every day you're
given and you gotta know
we're lucky to be in this uh country
despite the challenges
we're facing because nowhere else could
you have started this uh
bitcoin the way it started in my opinion
and nowhere else would you be able to
race
towards a vaccine like we're able to do
in this country and
by the way i think ultimately i wish
somebody pick up the tagline that every
one of us
americans should be interested in making
the world great again
that's a great way to end it congressman
um if people want to
find out more about you and uh and all
the great work you and your staff are
doing where can they go
[Laughter]
emer.gov dot us uh
i'm not gonna send you to emmer for
congress there's all kinds of social
media
all that stuff all you gotta do is type
in emmer and don't
ev don't ever ever forget me you'll
remember
awesome listen thank you so much for
doing this i think people are really
going to enjoy it we'll do it again in
the future
thanks pomp i look forward to meeting
you in person and stay healthy